welcome to this video play max harm from
the Netherlands I guess yep okay yeah
let's let's mix it up maybe the bloom
and fault yep I let's play the
bloomenveldt oh this is a very rare move
okay and I guess taking with the ponies
right getting the the center here should
be sown okay maybe this isn't so bad for
white I mean why not lucky 393 and beam
can be played yeah he's got 93 m play
against this lady six-night bd7
interesting maybe I should have given
the check and play 94 yeah I really
should have done that okay but then this
still should be a playable position
okay i want to block a four a five for
the moment intending 94 Oh p.m. defends
it like that interesting ok 94 94 is
just blundering material so not a good
idea yeah one problem is if I if I am
castle he takes d5 2297 check look very
nice I probably have to do something
else
thinking about might be 67 Knight b6 and
night see form may be very tough to play
my queen can also easily get in trouble
they can Bob castle yeah I cannot castle
because of my text e5 that's really a
problem
many play rating
green before there's always a five and
my queen can easily get trapped i Knight
f6 is a check of course I completely
overlook this this way I'm losing him ah
I'm losing a pawn what is he doing here
check I can take be too I probably must
take it may be here this tempo in night
takes a for I could have taken a foe
immediately actually I should have done
that ok but I don't really see how we
protect the pawn anyway
now i can probably take it next move
yeah we're looking very simple museum
okay just take it here covering here
maybe it takes on b6 and strengthens my
structure nope can I take a force still
push up d1 yup Bishop t1 is a problem
okay take he i can take c3m well still
very tricky this position yeah I should
just have taken a four out two months
ago it was much simpler
am I not taking a five next I hope I
just can't take a five I don't see why
not and then back to be six keep it
covered and then play t5i that this
looks ok now ok just prevent you five
and prepare d5
yeah d 5 next should be okay
that's it had some good defensive move
probably cannot go to f7 which I really
would like to do okay let's regroup it
to e 62 f son
yeah try to trade some pieces and next
term try use the bones check and d5 next
this is ok now really ok d5 it's just
this is a pretty simple technical task
no time morning promotion white resides
yeah but what is what a what a game in
the opening I just overlooked 95 I mean
I had seen that here of course Castle
Sam is not working due to 95 winning the
house yeah Queen d2 97 check check so
this i had seen so i thought okay i want
but still he had this move it probably
wasn't so terrible but I actually think
what I should have done in the opening
and which I failed to do I should have
given an early check here after this I
should really check in here check this
is probably I'm probably helpful last 93
94 is nice for me okay well this was
certainly not terrible for black but I
really overlooked yes and here of course
I just take I just need to take on a4ai
guess or is the bishop d1 actually there
should be one now
okay so i could do that played it all
right and maybe here i just need to take
it yeah the computer is giving all this
is equal at least I I wasn't worse and
after oops sorry um after a five like is
indeed much better after he blundered
upon it also leads to to a position now
where he cannot really attack my my
pawns they are all nicely protected the
King in the centres of course even
helpful to defend d6 all right hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching